I think it depends on individual
experiences in Iraq but i think that the
citizens of Baghdad who used to be
subjected to arbitrary killing and
imprisonment especially especially
brutal two young women by Santa machine
sons I think if you were democratically
inclined that you're very happy that
Sodom is saying is gone but I think
there's also frustration because of our
four years of failure failed policy in
Iraq and I understand that but I think
you're now seeing with a reverse flow of
refugees any more secure environment
Iraqis beginning to probably say I'm
glad that the Americans are here doing
the right thing but I think also the
Iraqis want more and more to take over
their own responsibilities and I hope
that the military is capable of doing
that I believe the military is capable
of doing it but I come around again to
my initial I answer to you they've got
to have a functioning central government
effectively
you